[Musique]
dans cette coquette pad poulet dans ses
piles ont zéro poulet et dans ce simili
poulet c'est toujours du poulet pour la
plupart des simili poulet qu'on retrouve
sur le marché ils sont faits de part de
viande de porc bienvenue dans le monde
du simili faut savoir quelles seront
celles du simili à la base comme son nom
l'indiqué on parle d'une copie d'une
imitation d'un aliment
les premières traces de simili poulet
dans la culture culinaire viennent de la
grande dépression américaine ou à cette
époque là en fait faut savoir que le
poulet était plus chère que le pas dans
les plus connus il y a aussi le simili
crabe et la plupart des 6 mg sont faits
d'une composition de plusieurs types de
poissons à chair blanche
on parle des années 70 environ a
commencé à inonder notre marché
probablement entre autres parce que le
crabe est un des fruits de mer les plus
délicats les plus délicieux et les plus
chers ou si on remplace on imite on
substitue par souci d'économie mais
aussi pour le côté pratique si je me
réfère aux années 60 où les femmes ont
commencé à s'émanciper ont voulu sortir
de cuisine et faire autre chose que
cuisiner donc les solutions pratiques
comme le dre mugello
les cristaux du par exemple ou même les
mélanges à gâteaux et des essais de
cette épopée locke que c'est transformer
toute la charcuterie qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui et éventuellement le fameux
signe du poulet tel qu'on le connaît
mais faire du faux c'est pas nouveau ça
vient de la chine et de l'inde avec la
philosophie bouddhiste où arrive la
notion de préserver la vie sous toutes
ses formes
alors pour préserver la vie sous toutes
ses formes on ne mangera pas d'animaux
on va être végétarien sauf que les
moines qui vont embrasser religion
philosophie là vont avoir à recevoir des
rois des grands dignitaires qui eux sont
habitués et surtout quand on est devant
on mange de la viande c'est un peu comme
ce que le tofu du côté du japon de la
chaîne et de l'inde va commencer à
utiliser pour donner l'impression qu'on
a une texture en fait qui rappelle la
viande
[Musique]
la nouvelle ère du simili les versions
végétal qui copient toutes sortes de
produits d'origine animale viande
surtout mais aussi fromages et autres
produits laitiers rendu au xxème siècle
avec les technologies la chimie les
inventions le colorant alimentaire mais
l'on va avoir à peu près tout à portée
de main pour pouvoir inventer à peu près
n'importe quoi pour faire du simili que
ce soit pour des raisons économiques ou
peut-être pour des raisons
philosophiques avec la remontée
graduelle du courant un végétarien et
maintenant vegan végétalien qui
viendrait redonner j'aurais peut-être
une nouvelle vie à ces techniques lol je
sais pas si vous avez fait l'expérience
de déguster certains de ces produits là
du côté de la viande pour le moment elle
et les copies qu'on se trouve à avoir
sont de plus en plus raffinés au sens de
qualité c'est à dire en termes de goûts
et de textures et dans certains cas des
copies qui sont vraiment assumé
du côté des produits laitiers par contre
au pis ça c'est plus récents comme
catégorie copie si je peux l'appeler
comme ça et de façon générale la le bob
laisse davantage
moi ça fait longtemps que cheville et
alien relie vichy rouen et
coordonnatrice du centre de recherche en
éthique de l'université de montréal et
les végétalienne depuis quinze ans
c'était pour des raisons liées à
l'éthique animale c'est une question de
justice animal sa peau était pour moi
très difficile mais je pense que ça
aurait été effectivement facilitée si
ces produits avaient été disponibles un
peu partout
à l'époque où je suis devenu payant donc
c'est bon avez vous un petit peu la bbc
en tout cas qu'est ce qu'on a ici ça
celui des jeunes et ça c'est un oeuf à
base de soya
puis le seynois le seul noir se ne
s'appelle calamane axel qui est sous le
feu social good les eaux
la couleur est donnée par quoi vous
donner avec les corps communs personnel
le week-end les abords base à soyaux et
ça c'est la fameuse saucisse gusta de
montréal dans les versions vg des simili
non seulement on remplace mais on imite
parfois de façon étonnante
ça ne prend des textures ça nous prend
aussi faut pouvoir avoir des références
on se retrouve un peu désarmée disant
devant jusqu'au comme chercheur comment
on peut s'alimenter comme on peut
inclure des protéines dans notre
alimentation
alors ces produits leur servent surtout
je pense pendant la période de
transition
le passage par exemple de mediatone
niveau rased digital a simplement
remplacé un produit d'origine animale
par des protéines végétales
c'est facile et grandement les choses on
n'a pas besoin tout de suite de revoir
toute notre répertoire culinaire donc
[Musique]
à l'aveuglé la texture est très simple
où est surprenant en même temps mais
vous perdez pas ce plaisir que vous avez
ou que vous avez eu de manger de la
viande qui il faut le dire au québec en
particulier aux etats-unis beaucoup
associé au plaisir familial des repas à
table où ça a été très dominant aussi
bien être animal ou considérations
environnementales
ces nouveaux simili sont chers et
parfois simili santé dans certains cas
ce que j'ai vu effectivement du côté des
étals étaient payés alors alors faut
faire attention pour plusieurs des
copies végétales et les ingrédients sont
très longues
parce qu'on a beaucoup de choses à
copier donc on veut copier le bout on
veut copier la texture on veut copier
les arts ont beaucoup de ses disciples
ne sont pas nécessairement nocifs pour
la santé mais ce qui contribue à la
santé évidemment non ils sont là
vraiment pour le produit
pour satisfaire les exigences sont nos
attentes en termes de goûts et textures
ce même bénéfice est véritablement la
santé dans tous les coptes pour garder
les tickets psy c'est une question de
goût mais là ça vous appartient